una multitud en gaza cortejó el funeral
de los muertos fruto del último ataque
aéreo de Israel con gritos de rabia y
también llantos dieron el último adiós a
tres líderes de la yihad islámica
Palestina entre ellos El comandante
tarek y del Din y también una decena de
civiles
mi hermano fue martirizado junto a su
hija mayor que tiene 11 años y su hijo
Ali que tiene 10
este enemigo es una entidad criminal que
desde su creación asesinó a líderes en
sus casas con sus familias e hijos no
los asesinaron en el campo de batalla
con sus hijos y mujeres el ejército de
Israel aseguró que cerca de 40 aviones
de combate participaron en lo que
denominó como ata
ques en los que atacaron las residencias
personales de sus objetivos además de 10
emplazamientos con armas e
infraestructuras tras los hechos la
llegada islámica ya ha advertido que
piensa responder con la misma altura
criminal una amenaza a la que Israel no
ha tardado en responder esta noche le
decimos a nuestros enemigos cualquier
escalada por su parte se encontrará con
una respuesta aplastante por nuestra
parte en lo que llevamos de año la
violencia en cisjordania en Jerusalén ha
aumentado y también en la franja de gaza
en total a más de 100 palestinos y una
decena de israelíes han muerto desde
enero